Et il a réfléchi pendant un assez long moment,
et il a finalement dit : « Madame, presque tout me manque. »
Et il est l'une des personnes les plus traumatisées
par cette guerre, que je connaisse.
« Madame, presque tout me manque. »
De quoi parle-t-il ?
Ce n'est pas un psychopathe.
Tuer des gens ne lui manque pas.
Il n'est pas fou. Se faire tirer dessus ne lui manque pas,
ni même voir ses amis se faire tuer.
Qu'est-ce qui lui manque ? Nous devons répondre à cette question.
Si nous voulons arrêter la guerre, nous devons répondre à cette question.
Je pense que ses compagnons lui manquent.
D'une certaine façon,
le contraire de tuer lui manquait.
Ce qui lui manquait, c'était la connexion
avec les autres hommes avec qui il était.
La fraternité est différente de l'amitié.
L'amitié arrive en société, évidemment.
Plus vous appréciez quelqu'un,
plus vous en ferez pour cette personne.
La fraternité n'a rien à voir
avec vos sentiments pour l'autre personne.
C'est un accord mutuel dans un groupe
de faire passer le bien-être du groupe,
la sécurité de chaque membre du groupe
avant les vôtres.
Dans les faits, vous dites :
« J'aime ces personnes plus que je ne m'aime. »
Brendan était un chef d'équipe
à la tête de trois hommes,
et le pire jour en Afghanistan -
Il a failli être tué tant de fois.
Cela ne le dérangeait pas.
La pire chose qui lui soit arrivée en Afghanistan
fut qu'un de ses hommes a été touché à la tête par une balle
dans le casque, ça l'a renversé.
Ils ont cru qu'il était mort.
C'était au milieu d'une énorme fusillade.
Personne n'a pu s'en occuper, et une minute plus tard,
Kyle Steiner s'est rassis,
il est revenu d'entre les morts, comme ça,
il est redevenu conscient.
La balle l'avait juste assommé.
Elle avait ricoché sur le casque.
Il se souvient des gens disant,
alors qu'il était à demi-conscient,
il se souvient des gens disant :
« Steiner a été touché à la tête. Steiner est mort. »
Et il pensait : « Je ne suis pas mort. »
Et il s'est assis.
Et Brendan s'est ensuite rendu compte
qu'il ne pouvait pas protéger ses hommes,
et la seule fois où il a pleuré en Afghanistan,
fut quand il s'en est rendu compte.
C'est cela la fraternité.
Cela n'a pas été inventé récemment.
Beaucoup d'entre vous ont sûrement lu « L'Iliade ».
Achille aurait sûrement risqué sa vie
ou donné sa vie pour sauver son ami Patrocle.
Durant la seconde guerre mondiale, il y a eu beaucoup d'histoires
de soldats blessés,
amenés dans un hôpital à l'arrière,
qui sont partis sans prévenir,
ont escaladé la fenêtre, se sont échappés par la porte,
sont partis sans prévenir, blessés,
pour retourner en première ligne
pour rejoindre leurs frères là-bas.
Pensez donc à Brendan,
pensez à tous ces soldats
qui ont une expérience similaire, un lien pareil,
dans un petit groupe,
où ils aimaient 20 autres personnes
d'une certaine façon, plus qu'ils ne s'aimaient eux-mêmes,
pensez à quel point cela fait du bien, imaginez-le,
et ils vivent cette expérience pendant un an,
et quand ils rentrent,
ils sont juste de retour dans la société
comme nous autres,
ne sachant pas sur qui ils peuvent compter,
ne sachant pas qui les aime, qui ils peuvent aimer,
ne sachant pas exactement ce que quelqu'un qu'ils connaissent
serait prêt à faire pour eux en cas de besoin.
C'est terrifiant.
Comparé à ça,
la guerre, psychologiquement, est en quelque sorte facile,
comparée à ce genre d'aliénation.
C'est pour cela que la guerre leur manque,
et c'est ce que nous devons comprendre
et, d'une manière, corriger dans notre société.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)